Evos two-year construction began by
digging 10 feet of dirt from what had
been a parking lot then they covered the
ground with a temporary layer of
concrete called a rat slab the rat slab
will provide a smooth surface for the
first parking level the day after the
rat slab is poured is day one for the
electrician's this is gonna be fire
alarm fire alarm security they are led
by supervisor Bob Mott this is my first
high-rise that I've been in charge of
but I got top notch guys welcome to ice
dam what we're doing right now is we're
laying out he's shooting down our boxes
so they're secure all the power out that
we need buried inside each of Evo's
concrete decks will be hundreds of
junction boxes for things like ceiling
lights and fire alarms with the concrete
you're just gonna see this and then the
hole inside and we come back and we
mount or a light or you know fire alarm
strobe or whatever it's gonna be right
there
each of these boxes needs to be
precisely placed to hold fixtures in
areas that won't be built for another
seven months
control line so make sure we make our
layout right make sure that when it's
said and done our fissures are straight
rather than like this so it looks
aesthetically pleasing they track which
type of box goes where with colored
spray paint yellow for lighting red for
fire alarm
the next day a crew of iron workers
begin laying down a dense grid of rebar
this rebar will reinforce a poured
concrete deck that'll be the first level
of underground parking
once the rebar is down the electrician's
return to connect their boxes together
with Smurf to take a sport over to that
take a smurf over to that we call it
Smurf - it's basically flexible PVC and
it's just a quick way to run conduit the
Smurf tubes will be used to get wire to
the junction boxes embedded in the
concrete deck it's critical that the
right tubes go to the right boxes those
I smoking crack that day or what
okay Oh EP b & e BL alright and then I
got to bring you a three-quarter for the
80s status alright I'll keep stringing
one-inch you're just gonna have to when
we do this you're gonna have to identify
yeah I'm supposed to have two days
typically I get a day